♪.
WILL: THERE IS A REASON WHY
CRIME IS ONE OF THE MOST
CONCERNING ISSUES FOR AMERICANS.
IT IS RAGING FROM CITY TO CITY.
PETE: JUST THESE PAST FEW WEEKS
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THE MOST
OUTRAGEOUS CRIMES CAUGHT ON
CAMERA, NOTABLY IN CITIES THAT
ARE DEEP BLUE WITH NEW BAIL
POLICIES AND PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTORS WHO ARE LETTING
CRIMINALS OUT OF JAIL.
SO LET'S GO OFF THE WALL TO SEE
A FEW OF THEM.
WILL, THE FIRST ONE STARTS IN
CHICAGO.
WILL: THIS IS ALL JUST FROM THIS
WEEK.
IN CHICAGO A CAR CARE BUSINESS
OWNER WENT INSIDE OF HIS
BUSINESS.
LEFT THE FRONT -- UNLOCKED.
WOULD CONDUCT A VIRTUAL MEETING.
HE LOOKS UP, THIS MAN COMES IN
WITH A GUN.
HE DOES SOMETHING PEOPLE
INCREASINGLY GOING TO BE APT TO
DO, HE FIGHTS BACK.
PETE: YEAH.
HE LUNGS AT THE GUN, WHEN YOU
WATCH THE CLIP.
SOMEHOW IT APPEARS THE GUN
MISFIRED OR DID NOT WORK
PROPERLY.
I MEAN WATCH THIS, HE HAS A GUN
WAVING AT HIS FACE.
HIS DOOR WAS UNLOCKED.
WILL: JAMMINGED.
PETE: HE IS TRYING TO RACK A
ROUND, HE CAN'T.
HE REALIZES THAT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY.
BY THE WAY THIS INDIVIDUAL
POINTING A GUN AT SOMEBODY ELSE
STILL AT LARGE, WHICH IS OFTEN
THE CASE IN A LOT OF THESE
SITUATIONS AS WELL.
PROBABLY HAS PREVIOUS CRIMINAL
RECORD, STILL AT LARGE.
THIS GUY ACTS ON HIS OWN.
WILL: NEW YORK CITY, WE'VE WAY
TOO MUCH OF THIS OVER MONTHS AND
THIS WEEK.
WE SAW ANOTHER SUBWAY RIDER
PUSHED ON TO THE TRACKS.
THIS TIME A 32-YEAR-OLD
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN RIDING
THE SUBWAY, PETE, SINCE HE WAS
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
PETE: HIS ENTIRE LIFE.
NO REASON TO THINK OTHERWISE.
32-YEAR-OLD, I DON'T KNOW IF HE
HAVE HIS NAME, LIFELONG
NEW YORKER.
THIS GUY EYEING HIM UP, LOOKING
FOR A TARGET, WEARING A MASK.
HE TEES OFF.
WILL: RANDOMLY.
PETE: THEY DON'T KNOW EACH OTHER
AT ALL.
WHAT DO WE KNOW?
THIS INDIVIDUAL HAD ALREADY DONE
20 YEARS BEHIND BARS FOR
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
SO AS WE OFTEN SEE IN THESE
CASES, PLENTY OF PRIOR CRIMINAL
RECORD.
WILL: THE VICTIM, HE SURVIVED.
WAS NOT HIT BY A TRAIN.
BROKE HIS COLLAR BONE.
HE WAS INJURED.
WE'RE SEEING WAY TOO MUCH OF
THAT EXACT TYPE OF CRIME IN
NEW YORK CITY.
PETE: ERIC ADAMS SAYS IT IS
SAFE.
WILL: STATISTICALLY, NO BIG
DEAL.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING YOU SEE
EVERY DAY.
THIS IS IN PASADENA, CALIFORNIA,
A WOMAN ATTACK AS HOME WITH A
GRANDMOTHER BABYSITTING AN
INFANT JUST ON THE OTHER SIDE,
ATTACKS IT WITH A PICK AXE.
SHE IS GOING AT THE WINDOWS,
WINDOW BY WINDOW ATTACKING WITH
A PICK AXE.
PETE: YEAH.
LIKELY SOME MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, WE'RE TOLD, IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE.
BY THE WAY THERE WAS A BABY
BEHIND ONE OF THOSE WINDOWS THAT
APPARENTLY, THE GRAND MARCH
PULLED THE BABY FROM UNDERNEATH
THE WINDOW BEFORE IT WAS
SMASHED.
AGAIN UNPROVOKED.
NO CONNECTION TO THE PEOPLE
INSIDE.
THE MENTAL HEALTH, AND, AT LEAST
IN THIS CASE WE KNOW WHO THE
PERPETRATOR WAS.
WILL: SHE WALKED AWAY WITH THE
PICK AXE SHRUNK OVER HER
SHOULDER, SAYING QUESTION,
QUESTIONS, I WILL BE BACK.
GET OUT.
WOW.
PETE: SPEAKING OF GET OUT, GO
DOWN TO NEW ORLEANS WHERE
CARJACKINGS ARE ON THE RISE.
THIS VIDEO OF A WOMAN WHO IS
WALKING OUT AFTER BUILDING,
LOCKED THE GATE, GETTING INTO
THE HONDA CRV, A MAN WHO HAS
BEEN HIDING IN THE BUSHES JUMPS
OUT, GRABS THE CAR, PUNCHES HER
AS YOU JUST SAW.
JUMPS IN, STEALS THE CAR,
CARJACKING WAY UP IN
NEW ORLEANS.
WILL: THIS MAN IS STILL AT
LARGE.
THE SUSPECT HAS NOT BEEN CAUGHT.
YOU POINT OUT, THESE CARJACKINGS
ON THE RISE.
THIS WOMAN TOTALLY UNSUSPECTING
AS SHE PULLS OUT OF THE
DRIVEWAY, WHACKS, HER, ASSAULTS
HER, PULLS HER OUT OF THE CAR.
PETE: THE VEHICLE WAS FOUND WITH
A FLAT TIRE FOUR HOURS LATER,
TAKEN TO A TOW YARD.
AS HAPPENS IN MINNESOTA,
NEW JERSEY, HAPPENS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
HE IS IN THE BUSHES, THINK ABOUT
THE FEAR, TERROR OF YOUR OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD, THE MIDDLE OF THE
DAY, CARJACKINGS WAY UP.
IT'S A CRIME THAT DOESN'T GET
REPORTED ENOUGH.
WILL: TUESDAY, ALL OF THESE JUST
FROM THIS WEEK FROM ALL ACROSS
THE NATION.
YOU CAN SEE WHY AMERICANS ARE
READY TO DO AWAY WITH POLL IS
LEADING IN RISING CRIME.
MAKING THEIR VOICE HEARD IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
PETE: TOTALLY RANDOM.
COULD BE ANYBODY.
FEAR IS SO IMPORTANT.
OFTEN NO ARRESTS, NO
CONSEQ